Pete Davidson and Kate Beckinsale pack
on the PDA the Saturday Night Live
comedian and the actress were spotted
making out on Monday night in Hollywood
as they left the after-party for the
premiere of Netflix's the dirt I have
worked for lecture records guys like a
recognition has a role in the Motley
Crue biopic posed for pix earlier in the
night on the red carpet sans Kate
wearing a green and white graphic
t-shirt black pants a matching blazer
white sneakers pink socks and dark
sunglasses and while they may have
arrived to the premiere of the film
separately they left the after-party
together that's Kate and Pete locking
lips in the backseat of a car the two
were first spotted flirting at the 2019
Golden Globes afterparty in January
since that night they've confirmed the
romantic suspicions by stepping out hand
in hand for an SNL afterparty and
smooching at a New York Rangers game
apparently people have a crazy
fascination with our age difference
but it doesn't really bother us Pete
broke his silence about his new leading
lady on Saturday Night Live addressing
their age difference head-on he's 25
she's 45 so if you have questions about
a relationship with a big age difference
just ask
lino DiCaprio Jason Statham Michael
Douglas Richard Gere Jeff Goldblum Scott
Disick Dane Cook Derek Jeter Bruce
Willis Harrison Ford Tommy Lee Alec
Baldwin Sean Penn and whoever the
president of France is Mel Gibson Billy
Joel Mick Jagger's Vesta Sloane Eddie
Murphy Kelsey Grammer Larry King Larry
King Larry King Stewart of Donald Trump
of course Pete split from his ex Ariana
Grande in October 2018
[Music]
the two called off their engagement
after several months together but not
before getting tons of tattoos dedicated
to one another on Sunday the break up
with your girlfriend singer debuted some
new ink on Instagram a delicate leaf
outline across her rib cage one of the
seven leaves is wrapped around her
tattoo of the word always attached she
got in June that many believed to be an
homage to her in Pete's shared love of
Harry Potter but the popstar made sure
to clarify that the art was not meant as
a disk to her ex she captioned the shot
quote not a cover-up
just involving
[Music]